بعد محاوله الاستيلاء على جامع سامراء
الكبير وتغيير اسمه عراقيون يصرخون بوجه
الوقف الشيعي كفافتنا وامريكا تحذر التيك
توك سلاح في حرب الصين على تايوان ورد
هاري وميجن اولادنا امراء بالولاده اهلا
بكم
البدايه مشاهدينا من العراق اللي فيها
حاله غضب وسخط شعبي كبير فيها وخصوصا في
مدينه سامراء التاريخيه التي تابعه
لمحافظه صلاح الدين ونقدر نعنون هذا الغضب
بجمله الخوف من الطائفيه والسبب هو مقام
بي الوقف الشيعي في جامع سامراء الكبير
ففجاه انتشر على المنصات بوست للعتبه
العسكريه التابعه للوقف الشيعي قالت في
انه راح تفتح جامع صاحب الامر من بعد ما
انتهت من اعمال ترميم القبه القبه اللي
بتتكلم عنها او بيتكلم عنها هذا البوست
تحديدا هي قبه جامع سامراء الكبير وهنا
الناس دارت طائرتها واعتبروا اللي بيعملوه
الوقف الشيعي محاوله للاستيلاء على الجامع
التابع من الاساس للوقف السني ديوان الوقف
السني اصدر فورا بيان استنكر في الموضوع
ووصف خطوه الوقف الشيعي بالاستفزازيه
واعتبرها اغتصاب للاراضي وطالب الجهات
المعنيه بالتدخل لوقف اللي جالس يصير
علماء وعشائر سمراء كمان طلعوا في بيان
صادر عن المجمع الفقهي العراقي وعبروا عن
استيائهم ورفضهم
ات عنيفه
تكاد تذهب بالبقيه الباقيه من تماسكه
يفاجئنا الجهه المسؤوله عن اعمار العتبه
العسكريه
بتغيير اسم الجامع الكبير في سامراء
محاوله للاستحواذ عليه
بحجه ترميم قبته
وقد حذر رسولنا الكريم
صلى الله عليه وسلم من اغتصاب الارض
فكيف باغتصاب بيوت الله تعالى
فضلا عما سيعقبه من اشعال لنيران الطائفيه
واذكاء للهيبها
ومن بعدها توالت البيانات والاستنكارات من
مختلف الجمعيات او الجهات والجمعيات
والاحزاب والتحالفات الدينيه والسياسيه
وكمان من العراقيين والكل كان لسان حاله
جمله واحده كثافتنا طائفيه وليش ممكن
يسووا كذا وايش الهدف اللي اشعال الفتنه
امام كل هذا مصدر اي بيان رسمي او تعليق
من الحكومه ولا حتى الوقف الشيعي طلع رد
لكنهم مسحوا البوست اللي فيه الاسم متغير
السرعه الامريكي الصيني مكمل وتيك توك جزء
لا يتجزا منه فمن بعد حظر التطبيق على
الاجهزه الرسميه والموظفين الحكوميين في
امريكا واوروبا وكندا كمان حاليا بيدرس
منح اداره الرئيس جو بايدن مزيد من
الصلاحيات للتصدي لتهديد تيك توك وفي كلام
على انه ممكن يكون حتى حظر كامل للتطبيق
امس مدير مكتب التحقيقات الفيدرالي كريستي
وفي اجابه على اسئله في لجنه الاستخبارات
في مجلس الشيوخ فاجانا بتصريح صادم فقال
انه الصين في حال غزل تايوان فتكتوك راح
يكون سلاح اساسي من اسلحتها كيف مدير الاف
بي اي قال انه اولا لانها ببساطه حتتحكم
ببيانات ملايين الاشخاص اللي بيستخدموا
تيك توك وثانيا انه رح تحاول تاثر على
الراي العام من خلال محتوى فيديوهات
التطبيق يعني حضروا رسميا اسمعنا كلام
منهم ومن كندا ومن اوروبا عن مخ للامن
القومي ومخاوف النصين كمان كحكومه لها
علاقه بالتطبيق لكن كلام على انه تيك توك
سلاح في حروب هذه جديده يعني اول مره
الصراحه نسمعها تيك توك طبعا من اول يوم
اصلا يعني بتنكر تماما انه لها اي علاقه
مع الحكومه الصينيه وبتقول مو لاننا شركه
صينيه فالحكومه بتتحكم فينا ورئيس الشركه
صرح نصا هذا الاسبوع وقال حكومه الصين
عمرها ما طلبت مننا بيانات او معلومات
مستخدمين وحتى لو طلبت ما راح نعطيها
الشركه كانت اصلا كمان ابدت استيائها
وامتعاضها من حضرها من الاجهزه الحكوميه
في امريكا وكندا واوروبا ويبدو انه في كل
الاتهامات لكنها حاسه ان الحظر هذا حيؤثر
عليها بشكل او باخر وتطمن الغرب باي شكل
عن اليه جديده في تخزين بيانات المستخدمين
الاوروبيين المحليين هذا العام وقالت انه
راح تعمل قريبا مركز جديد للبيانات في
ايرلندا ومركز في النرويج
وانه اللي راح يدير المركزان طرف ثالث
مستقل ما له علاقه بتيك توك وهذا حيمنع
نقل البيانات خارج المنطقه وراح يتقلص
امكانيه اطلاع الموظفين على بيانات
المستخدمين
احنا من جانبنا لمع هذا الجانب ولا مع ذلك
يعني لكن حقيقه الطرفين جالسين بيعملوا
اشياء بتطرح تساؤلات مهمه بتعني الاف بي
اي لمن يقولوا انه الصين راح تستخدم تيك
توك سلاح في الحرب على التايوان على ايش
معتمده مجرد انه التطبيق صيني يعني طب ما
كده ممكن نقول مثلا انه امريكا بتستعمل
فيسبوك وانستجرام يعني هدولي تطبيقات
امريكيه يعني وعن جانب الاخر كمان اللي
تكتب جلسه بتسويه كمان مو منطقي يعني
اوروبا قالت خايفه على البيانات
مستخدمينها قاموا اخذوا اجراءات اضافيه
لحمايه بيانات المستخدمين طيب ليه ما
عملته كده من اول يعني وليه الان عاملين
للمستخدمين الاوروبيين بعد كمان ما عملتوه
كمان قبلها لمستخدمين الامريكيين هم بس
يعني الاوروبيين والامريكيين المهمين
والباقي مو مهم تنضم الينا صانع المحتوى
التقني فيصل السيف اهلا فيك معنا فيصل
فيصل انا طبعا موضوعي معك عن تيك توك
واللي بيصير من امريكا وكذا بس انت الان
موجود في مؤتمر بيبان باين وراك انه ما
شاء الله المكان يعني عامر فاحكي لي ايش
بيصير عندك كيف المؤتمر
ناشئه والمتوسطه شيء جدا عظيم ولا عمرها
صارت 20,000 فرصه
عليه اي مباشر بشكل جدا رهيب في النص ساعه
بدل تقريبا طيب خلينا نترك بيبان
وبالتوفيق طبعا
للمؤتمر كل شيء خلينا ننتقل الان لتيك توك
لما نقول انه الامريكان او الاف بي اي
تحديدا طالعينه بيقولوا انه الصين راح
تستخدم تيك توك سلاح يعني هل هذا الكلام
منطقي يعني يستخدم كسلاح في حرب
ممتاز جدا السؤال لو رجعنا لمثال فيسبوك
هذا الامر صار توجيه ساعتها واستخدام احد
الادوات اوكي يعني لو انا مثلا من الصين
الان اقدر اقول لهم طب ما انتم كمان عندكم
سلاح فيسبوك مثلا
100% الفيسبوك نتكلم على انستغرام نتكلم
على
منصات جوجل وغيرها في جعل محتوى يظهر عن
محتوى طيب الان معلوماتنا نحن موجودين
يعني مثلا عند ابل عند سامسونج عند يعني
كل احد موجوده اللي بنستخدمه عندهم
معلوماتنا كيف ممكن يستخدموا هذه
المعلومات لانه الواضح انه هو اللي بينظر
له كالشيء الاساسي او الذهب الحقيقي هي
المعلومات كيف ممكن لدوله تستفيد من
المعلومات
صح يقدر يخلق ورائي عام بحيث انه انواع
المحتوى التي تساند ارائهم يدفوها
بالخوارزميات لناس يمكن ما يكون عندهم هذا
الميول فبالت مع الوقت مع التكرار يغيروا
رايهم طيب بس لما في نفس الوقت نجي على
الناحيه الثانيه وبنشوف انه طيب يا جماعه
لا تقلقوا اول شيء الامريكان راحوا عملوا
لهم انه مكان داخل امريكا يشيل المعلومات
او البيانات المستخدمين هناك الاوروبيين
الان بيقولوا لهم حبايبي يلا نحن كمان
حنسوي لكم الان نفس الشيء طيب معناه في
شيء في الموضوع يعني ما دام بيسووا خطوات
زي كذا وبعدين نحن بيانات
المشرعه في كل دوله من هيئات اتصالات
وزارات هم لهم الحقيه بالذات في المعلومات
المستخدمين في الدوله انها تبقى المعلومات
في الدوله المستضيفه بنفس المستخدمين فاذا
المستخدم في امريكا عادي هي مساله استضافه
معلومات بس الموضوع ما هو بالامني زي ما
هم يتخيل بس محوره الكلام واستخدامه لم
هذا الامر اللي قاعد يصير هذا الامر شفناه
عبر 15 سنه حقت هي السنوات الماضيه ما
كانت القوه الاعلاميه بتواصل اجتماعي
موجوده الا عند الامريكان وبالتالي لما
صار في منصه تتنافس بشكل ضخم مع اقتصاد
امريكي كبير من شبكات التواصل وايضا مع
مستخدمين صاروا يقدروا يتم تاثيرهم من
منصه خارجيه عن تاثيرها من منصات داخليه
هنا قلنا عن الموضوع انه لا في تغيير عام
وفي اشياء جدا حساسه ممكن الامر واكيد
وواقعي ولكن العلاقات الحميده تسبب عدم
وجود هذا التوتر بس تعرف كمان فيصل يعني
كمان يعني الصينيين لما بيجوا بيقولوا تيك
توك انه لا عمرهم ما بيطلبوا منا معلومات
الحكومه احنا ما لنا دخل فيهم يعني هذه
واسعه كمان شويه معلش يعني
صادقه ومعاكي حق ولكن الامر بطبيعه الحال
مع كل المنصات الحكومات تطلب منها معلومات
نفس المسجلين في المنصات امر طبيعي وما
منه خجله وما منه شيء
تويتر وكذا بيطلعوا تقارير دوريه بيتكلموا
عن طلبات الحكومات منهم يعني صح
فالامر حميد كويس بس استخدام هذا الامر
واللي هو اتوقع انه الجانب الاقتصادي هو
اللي قاعد ياثر على امريكا اكثر من اي
جانب ثاني حيث انهم ينصه غير امريكيه تحصل
على اموال المسلمين في امريكا على هذه
المنصه واول كانت الحاله انه الفيس
والانستجرام المنصات الامريكيه يعلن عليها
المعلنين الامريكي فالفلوس منهم وفيهم
فالحين الفلوس تطلع لبره هنا المشكله
الاقتصاديه واللي واجهتها هواوي ايضا في
تقنيات الجوالات اوكي طيب تسلم لي يا فيصل
واستمتع بيفان وشكرا لك كان معنا صانع
المحتوى التقني فيصل السيف شكرا لك
[موسيقى]
عاد الثنائي ذوق وذوق الامير هاري وزوجته
الى العناوين من يومين والسبب من جديد هو
الالقاب فيوم الاربعاء صدر بيان عن
الثنائي بيعلن تعميد ابنتهم اللي بتبلغ من
العمر سنه وتسعه اشهر والتعمير صار فلوس
انجلوس مكان اقامتهم الحالي وقيل انه تمت
دعوه جدها الملك تشارلز وزوجته كامله
وامير ويلز وزوجه الاميره كاثرين ولكنهم
ما حضروا التعميد ولا الحفله اللي عملوها
الثنائي في منزلهم في كاليفورنيا اللافت
في بيان هاري وميجن كان انه سموا ابنتهم
ولاول مره اميره للتذكير لما لبست انولدت
كانت الملكه اليزابيث عايشه وحسب الدستور
الانجليزي اولاد هاري وميجن ما ياخذوا لقب
امير واميره لانهم ليسوا احفاد من الدرجه
الاولى للملكه وحتى موقع القصر الرسمي كان
حاطط اسمائهم في سلم العرش لكن جنب
اساميهم حاطط مس اند مستر او ماستر عفوا
ولكن من التولي جدهم الامير تشارلز الحكم
والاسئله بتحوم حول الموضوع لانه المفروض
وفقا للدستور وبما انه جدهم المباشر صار
ملك انه يصيروا امير واميره وصار في كلام
انه هل رح يعطي الملك الان
ارتشيل يكون هذا غصن زيتوني يقدموه
للثنائي اللي تخلوا عن مهامهم الملكيه
وغادروا بريطانيا من عشرين عشرين عشان كده
لما طلع بيان التعميد ونحط قبل اسم ليليت
لقب اميره الناس بدات تسال الطفله اخذت
اللقب ولا هاري وميجان من مخهم كده سموا
البنت اميره ولا ايش اللي صاير بالضبط
الجدل هذا كله ردوا عليه الثنائي بتصريح
جديد على لسان المتحدث باسمهم قالوا انه
اولادنا امير واميره بالولاده لانه جدهم
حاليا هو الملك وما فات كثير وقت على
التصريح الا وغير القصر الملكي البريطاني
المكتوب على الموقع الرسمي وصار مكتوب
الامير ارتي والاميره ليليبت في ترتيب
العرش طبعا لازم نذكر انه صحيح اخذوا لقب
امير واميره لكنهم مو اصحاب سمو ملكي مثل
ابوهم اللي كمان هو انسحب منه لقب سمو
ملكي ايضا لانه لم يعد عضو عامل في الاسره
المالكه
[موسيقى]
شارك صباح اليوم رائد الفضاء الاماراتي
سلطان النيادي لقطات مذهله وجميله جدا
لكوكب الارض من محطه الفضاء الدوليه مع
متابعي على تويتر ومع الفيديو غرا لمتابعي
وقلهم انه حبيت اشارككم معي هذه اللحظات
اللي بشوف فيها الارض لاول مره من وحده
المراقبه قبول علامه محطه الفضاء الدوليه
خلينا نشوف اللي شافوا سلطان
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته
هذا وعدتكم
معاكم نشوف اول مناظر
خلونا نشوف
وكنا فوق افريقيا
[موسيقى]
برفقه فريق مهمه
فضائيه في تاريخ العرب واللي بتمتد لي سته
اشهر وراح يشارك في تجارب علميه في عشر
مجالات حيويه طوال مده المهمه الرحله او
المهمه هذه كانت من المقرر انه تنطلق في
السابع والعشرين من فبراير لكن اتاجلت
بسبب عطل في المعدات الارضيه وتم اطلاق
المركبه بنجاح يوم الخميس الماضي من مركز
كندي للفضاء اللي سابع لوكاله ناسا ووصلوا
بالسلامه
احتضنت الرياض امس واحده من اكبر الحفلات
الغنائيه واضخمها واللي جمعت كبار النجوم
على مسرح واحد نحن بنتكلم عن محمد منير
عمرو دياب انغام احمد عدويه كلهم غنوا على
مسرح ابو بكر سالم بقياده المايسترو هاني
فرحات واخراج المخرج الكبير خيري بشاره
وكلهم تجمعوا للاحتفال بالموسيقار الكبير
هاني شنوده الحفل حضروا رئيس هيئه الترفيه
المستشار تركي ال الشيخ وقدمته انغام
وتضمن تكريم للموسيقار الكبير وحضروا غير
اللي شاركوا وقدوا فيه مجموعه كبيره جدا
من كبار نجوم مصر والعالم العربي كلهم
تجمعوا في ليله ذكريات هاني شنوده اللي
سمعنا فيها اجمل الحان واعماله وباصوات
كبار النجوم انا مشاهدينا راح اترككم مع
مقتطفات من اجمل ما جاء في الحفل واعود
والقاكم الاحد ان شاء الله في امان الله
امي الحبيبه ام الحنون انا كنت فين قبلك
انا ومن غيرك ازاي اكون امي الحبيب امي
الحنون سامحيني يا حضن الحنان سامحيني لا
لا لا لا
سامحيني لو خدني الزمان سامحيني
اللي البسكو على جسر الص
دى بدات سعادته تسافر في المدى زحمه وانا
رايح
[موسيقى]
اقول له
كلام بيني وبينه معاك
الله
بيني وبينه
معاه
[موسيقى]
واروح هناك
هنا او هناك
[موسيقى]
بعشق البحر زيك يا حبيبتي
عنك مجنون
[موسيقى]
زعلان زعلت
انا بعشق السما
علشان زيك
اوعاك
[موسيقى]
حبيبه وابي
بعيوني
[موسيقى]
بعشق السماء